de nos jours manger bien et sans risque
peut être un vrai casse tête
pour chantal une mère de famille
soucieuse du contenu de ces assiettes
faire les courses peut parfois
ressembler à un véritable parcours du
combattant
démonstration immédiate dans une grande
surface
à midi je voudrais faire donc qu'un
poulet mais j'hésite un petit peu j'ai
entendu parler poulet à la dioxine
jeu m'interroge quand je suis désolé
mais la dioxine suprême parce que c'est
à mais ça c'est mieux oui je
tous les fermiers
à mais c'est un pool et biologiques et
put et bah je vais pas hésiter élevé en
plein air 91 jours minimum puisque ses
marques et ben moi je dis pas
madame bonjour
fromage au lait cru ya pas de problème à
aucun ne s'est pas entendu parler de la
listériose et cetera donc
pas du tout du tout du tout du tout je
peux le manger en toute confiance est un
peu du marché du cvc l'émission à ce
sujet il ya eu une intoxication
alimentaire avec notre hommage en orient
qu'une inquiétude à l'écouté jousset
confiance notamment l'état morceau s'il
vous plaît
je regarde toutes les viandes et puis
s'cusez moi depuis l'histoire de la
vache folle je m'interroge qu'est ce que
c'est que ça le veau aux hormones
le bafin anglais le bac français je ne
sais plus je
plutôt d'hésiter puis j'ai tellement
peur de tomber malade je n'en mange
[Musique]
j'ai entendu parler de soja
génétiquement modifiés donc je vais sans
doute rendu maïs du maïs ben voilà
du maïs dit sans ogm ont dit sans ogm
bon ça doit te liées à la génétique
c'est-à-dire le maïs qui n'est pas
modifié mais bon je veux vous dire
exactement ce que ça veut dire je ne
sais pas
ça fait un peu peur fois
[Musique]